-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis yesterday
signed a bill that allows
residents to carry
concealed loaded weapons
without a permit.
UConn won the NCAA tournament,
and Finland join NATO.
And I think that's
all the other stuff.
Now, former president Trump
was arraigned today
inside the New York
County Criminal Court
in lower Manhattan.
And I think it really says
something that the craziest part
of that sentence
is still "former president."
That guy was the president
of the country.
If you asked for the manager
at Best Buy
and that guy came over,
you'd say, "No, the manager."
That's right --
former president Trump
was arraigned today
in Manhattan.
And like anyone else,
Trump is presumed innocent
until he outright confesses
on Truth Social.
Trump was arraigned today
inside a New York courtroom.
Cameras weren't allowed, but
they did have a sketch artist.
Former president Trump
was set to speak tonight
at Mar-a-Lago following his
arraignment today in New York.
Wait. They're letting him go?
Does anything scream
flight risk
more than a guy
with his own plane?
It's a flight guarantee.
Attorney Todd Blanche announced
yesterday that he's joined
former president Trump's
criminal defense team
and said joining the team was
"an opportunity
he could not pass up."
An opportunity to what?
Also go to prison?
Yeah, I mean, who wouldn't want
to join the illustrious ranks
of Michael Cohen
and the guy who didn't know
Four Seasons was a hotel?
New York Mayor
Eric Adams warned yesterday
that the city is prepared for
former president Trump's
arraignment and said,
"While there may be
some rabble-rousers
thinking about coming
to our city tomorrow, our
message is clear and simple --
control yourselves."
My question is, where was
that leadership before SantaCon?
Kellen Curry,
an Afghanistan war veteran
and former executive
at J.P. Morgan,
announced this week
that he will challenge New York
Congressman George Santos in
the Republican primary.
Sounds impressive.
Do we have a photo of Curry?
George!
Disney C.E.O. Bob Iger
criticized Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis yesterday
for his decision
to strip the company of its
special self-governing status
and, to get him back, announced
Minnie is just Mickey in drag.
Paris residents over the weekend
voted to ban electric scooters
from the city,
which is wise, because
it's really hard to fall in love
with someone once you've
seen them ride a scooter.
And, finally,
today was Tell a Lie Day.
Said one celebrant,
"Not guilty."
And that -- You guys,
that was the monologue.
We're off and running.
[ Cheers and applause ]